you know airfares have gone sky high in
recent months and airlines have been
shrinking the size of their seats for
years well now the faa is asking for
public feedback on the size and safety
of airline seats four years ago congress
ordered the faa to set some new
standards to ensure that passengers can
evacuate any airliner in 90 seconds or
less
chris van cleeve's been following this
story he is at washington's reagan
national airport good morning chris
good morning
you can see why this seat size debate is
taking off as the faa is asking for
people to weigh in on this issue but
let's be clear this comment period is
part of the process to create a new
regulation and the faa isn't interested
in hearing from you about how you like
the in-flight experience or if you think
your seats are comfortable they are
focused on safety and in this case
how close is too close to get out in a
hurry
to study the safe size of airline seats
the faa used this simulated cabin in
2019 they showed us it can be filled
with smoke and plunged into darkness but
that's not how the agency did its
testing we're going to try to minimize
the variables to the ones that are
important for this particular test leave
everything come this way the volunteer
passengers who participated in simulated
evacuations did have varying seat sizes
but did not have to deal with real life
obstacles like bags smoke comfort
animals or the dark and they were in
groups of 60. that's fewer people than
are on many regional jets the faa found
seat size and spacing did not adversely
affect the success of emergency
evacuations but because all participants
were able-bodied adults under 60 then
faa administrator steve dixon
acknowledged the results are useful but
not necessarily definitive
this was not representative of the
flying public congressman steve cohen
authored the legislation requiring the
seed size study the american public is
becoming more and more obese and the
seats are getting smaller and smaller do
you worry that you wouldn't be able to
get out quickly if you needed to and
indeed i do airline seat width is down
as much as four inches over the last 30
years to as little as 16 inches wide and
seat pitch has shrunk from about 35
inches to 31 and in some cases as little
as 28 inches allowing airlines to add
more seats they can then sell
the group flyers rights estimates only
about 25 percent of passengers one in
four actually fit in those seats and
more than half of flyers in a recent
survey were dissatisfied with the
legroom and economy what do you think of
the size of airline seats right now i
think they're tiny i'm foot nine
and i typically fly with my knees to my
chest
for several hours long it's challenging
on average i think that the seats are
too small that would be a great
improvement to have the seats much
larger for everybody
the faa says it's focused on identifying
the minimum seat spacing necessary to
safely evacuate an airliner in 90
seconds its review of 10 years of
incidents found the overall level of
evacuation safety was very high human
behavior of course is a critical factor
if a plane must be evacuated in 90
seconds or less when american airlines
flight 383 had an engine fire on takeoff
in 2016 it took nearly two and a half
minutes to get everyone off in part
because passengers grabbed their luggage
and everyone did get off that flight
okay in the u.s ultra low cost carriers
have seats that are about 28 inches
apart the faa found seats that are
closer together than that could present
a real challenge to getting out of the
plane in a hurry this comment period is
open for 90 days you can weigh in at
regulations.gov but remember they are
looking at safety not comfort nate
chris i hear you wow i'm not good both i
just like that they're asking for input
yeah right right i've gotten more nicks
and bruises from trying to get in and
out of the seats like scrapes bruises
yeah it's not comfortable or at least
they're trying to do something about it
this is good yeah